there's a sense of relief in the
nation's capital and the rest of the
country sightseers wandering through
Federal areas that could have been shut
down if the funding crisis was not
averted with ours to spare hopefully
Congress can get their act together and
that we can avoid any kind of future
damages that might incur to our families
and to Americans some expressing hope
for a new era in bipartisanship I think
it's good thing that it's continuing it
continues the flow of energy between all
the parties to think about different
options and create a great option and
action plan moving forward but Hardline
conservatives are Furious that the house
Speaker did not include the spending
cuts they demanded in the compromise
Bill known as a continuing resolution
that will fund government for 45 days
Kevin McCarthy describing himself as
being the adult in the Republican room
insisting he welcome any leadership
challenge Kevin McCarthy's going to get
his wish I don't think the adult in the
room would allow America to sit a top a
33 trillion do debt facing $2.2 trillion
annual deficits the house speaker was
dismissive Matt voted against the most
conservative ability to um protect our
border secure our border he's more
interested in securing TV interviews
than doing something he wanted to push
us into a shutdown even threatening his
own District with all the military
people there who would not be paid and
at the White House frustration if not
anger at the ongoing political
infighting quite frankly I'm sick and
tired I'm sick and tired of the
brinksmanship and so are the American
people I've been doing this you all
point out to me a lot a long time I've
never quite seen a republican Congress
or any Congress act like this for now
anyway politicians and the country's
people can take a breath one crisis is
being averted but the battle is far from
over over the next 45 days one is likely
to see a repeat of the divisiveness
within Congress within the Republican
party and a continuation of that
brinkmanship Mike Hannah aljazera
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer